("Hail to the
Chief"/Presidential anthem)
- Goodnight, and God bless.
- In the name of the father,
the son, and the Holy Spirit
shit.
- [Voiceover] And, cut! Alright,
that's an hour for lunch.
- Sandwich right
here, Mr. President
- Oops! Oops, I do believe
I ordered some extra mayo
- Oh no.
Oh no!
Oh hell no!
You all got to be out
yo god-damned minds!
Can a brotha get some
ma-yo-nnaise up in this bitch?!
- I can make do
- [Key] Oh no! I'm the
most powerful motha fucka
in the god-damned world!
And you know, right
now in France,
Nicolas Sarkozy,
with his little ass,
is eatin a fuckin
tub of mayonnaise.
- Do you have a
hard time believing
that President Sarkozy
doesn't get a tub
full of mayonnaise
when he asks for it?
Maybe it's just me?
- It is not just you!
It is not just you!